Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Rollercoasters may have originated from Russian
Mountains built in the 17th century - these
were large ice hills held with wooden supports
and we've been innovating amusement rides
ever since like this 1919 concept that shot
passengers out of a cannon in a bullet-shaped
capsule to land in a giant waterslide and
end up in the lake below.
What the FAK!?
The facts and knowledge on Roller Coasters.
People take 1.7 billion amusement park rides
every year in the U.S. alone and the chances
of being injured while riding is only 1 in
24 million but riding on roller coasters can
be extremely scary because of cognitive dissonance
where part of you understands there's no real
danger while the other part experiences genuine
fear.
Located in Abu Dhabi, The Formula Rossa is
the world's fastest roller coaster clocking
in at 240 km per hour.
It accelerates to top speed in less than five
seconds using a hydraulic launch system that
generates the velocity similar to aircraft
carrier steam catapults.
Riders are required to wear protective eyeglasses
because of the risk of impact with airborne
objects like insects.
The Kingda Ka in Jackson New Jersey holds
the record for tallest roller coaster with
the main top hat tower reaching 456 feet.
After a 90 degree roll to the right it reaches
the peak and then drops 418 feet down through
a 270 degree right-handed spiral.
The ride lasts 28 seconds and in 2009 it was
shut down for 3 months after suffering damage
from a lightning strike.
But U.S. Thrill Rides is planning to take
the tallest record away with the Polercoaster.
It is slated to open in 2016 in Florida it
will send riders down 520 feet at more than
60 mph.
The Steel Dragon 2000 opened in Japan in the
year 2000, which was "The Year of the Dragon".
It holds the record for the longest track
length at 8,133 feet and 2 inches.
Because the construction required so much
steel for earthquake protection it cost over
50 million dollars to build.
Also located in Japan, The Takabisha is known
for having a drop angle of 121 degrees making
it the steepest roller coaster in the world.
The world's tallest vertical loop stands at
160 feet during the Full Throttle roller coaster
in California.
There are 18 riders per train and each ride
is under a minute long, giving it the capacity
to have 800 riders per hour.
Full Throttle also features the first top
hat over a loop.
A top hat is a common element in roller coasters
where there is a hill with a 90 degree ascent
and descent.
But if you want to go on the roller coaster
with the most inversions you'll have to head
to the United Kingdom to ride the Smiler.
It has a world record of 14 total inversions
that are supposed to make you laugh, not barf.
A wing coaster is a type of steel roller coaster
where pairs of riders sit on either side of
the track and there is nothing above or below
them.
The Gatekeeper, the fifth wing coaster in
the world, is located in Sandusky, OH.
Opened in 2013 and has the highest inversion
in the world measuring 170 ft. and in the
wing coaster category it holds the record
for the longest, fastest, longest drop, and
most inversions.
When riders experience a moment of free falling
with at least a 90 degree drop it is considered
a Dive Coaster.
And the Griffon roller coaster in Virginia
is the tallest and the fastest dive coaster
to date at 205 feet tall and 71 mph.
There are also no other dive coasters that
feature floorless trains and it's the only
roller coaster of its kind to have more than
one inversion.
The Tatsu is a flying roller coaster that
gives riders a flight sensation.
They're suspended in a horizontal position
where the cars are secured under the track
and the rider's backs are parallel to it.
It holds records for the highest (170 ft),
fastest (62 mph), and longest of its kind.
It's the only one to feature a zero gravity
roll and had the world's highest pretzel loop.
I'm gonna leave you with this.
What's the name of this roller coaster and
what's its significance?
Before we go here's last video's winner.
Leave your answer in the comments below and
as always - thanks for watching!